there let's let's uh let's jump back to
netflix we have the story from cnbc
netflix shares crater 25
after company reports it lost
subscribers for the first time in more
than 10 years get woke go
broke
that's it netflix
i mean they've done some things that are
good but i think the narrative the
machine it's it's fumbling it's bumbling
it's falling apart regular people are
tuning into shows like this the media
landscape is heavily diversifying people
are sick and tired of the machine they
want something real and authentic isn't
it interesting how poorly tech companies
seem to be aging over the past 10 or 20
years yeah
i mean everyone everyone says i loved
netflix when it first started now it's
absolutely awful same with facebook same
with twitter basically every social
media company it's because the cia is my
guess is that intelligence agencies are
are webbed in with these things and
making them do stuff and give
information away and spying and when the
codes aren't the algorithms aren't free
software like copy left licenses like
agpl3 you have no way of verifying that
these people if they may look like
they're being run by the people that own
the company but they're being run by
blackrock and vanguard and state street
well and you look at you know you look
at something like netflix and it's funny
you mentioned that because i always
point out that so
you know what's the world economic forum
slogan that you'll own nothing and be
happy well when's the last time you
actually bought a movie
like a physical
actual movie that you own and now i know
some people out there that are total
cinephiles and will go get they'll get
the 4k
you know or the blu-ray and they want it
they want to have that in their system
but i think for the vast majority of
people we all switched to renting movies
and then streaming movies that we do not
own that we do not control so there's
this big i guess controversy about the
new harry potter prequel because there's
i guess a gay scene or a gay line in it
that got edited out of the chinese
version it's like six seconds or
something right but my point is though
is when it comes to netflix or amazon
prime or any of these things if there's
something that's in an old scene of a
movie or a scene in an old movie that
they want excised out if they want
changed if they want removed they can
just go in and do that and if you don't
own a physical copy of the original film
you're never going to know and here's
the even better part if you never had a
copy of the film you wouldn't even know
yeah exactly and that happens with some
chinese fight club they did it oh i i
was unaware they changed the ending well
there are other films too where it's not
even necessarily done for political
reasons so for example and the last of
the mohicans you can't really find
copies of that film that aren't the
director's cut so the theatrical release
is only available on vhs which is really
annoying well this is a star wars like
that yes that's also true and so even
when it's not done for political reasons
some sometimes you just want to watch
the actual original version of the film
but you're absolutely correct that when
it comes to looking back on media from
the past and saying that was deeply
offensive and insensitive we have to
change it they're not going to be above
doing so we were we were watching um
the
uh
the original ducktales with my kids and
um just going through cranking through
the old ducktales tv show from the 90s
you know 80s 90s great great thing and i
wasn't doing it on disney plus and no
i'm not going to say which side i used
um but i realized because we're just
going through episode by episode there's
a whole episode about a civil war
reenactment
and in this episode launchpad plays on
the side of the rebels and they're in
gray and there are confederate flags all
over this episode so from the 90s the
show's off the air right now okay our
internet is working just fine
oh but no one can see anything
i can still use the internet i can still
chat i'm i know exactly why this is
happening too hmm
you said the forbidden name
you think that word
youtube took us down i just got a
message from our tech guys that we may
be having internet issues the internet's
working just fine i can see the bit rate
is up i can load websites i can use my
phone
but uh you know i'm i think we're just
not repeating i'm seeing live
no there's there's no show still not
live no not live interesting show's
frozen show
let's keep it rolling for the people on
timcast.com for the podcast and rumble
yeah see this is why you guys for those
that are listening on the other podcast
on uh youtube we're down we gotta go to
rumble anyway
[ __ ] youtube [ __ ] the [ __ ] the spy
networks [ __ ] so you can say the
name of libs of tiktok you still can't
swear well i can do whatever i want i
mean you're i'm still family friendly we
still put this
yeah that's crazy so i have it pulled up
on my computer and it is it is just
buffering on ian yeah but our stream's
working i still see the chat too yeah
chat's working internet's working
everything's working but the show's out
i'm getting a message that we may have
to switch over to a different network
i don't know if that matters
but uh we will try
so the the the issue is that our
internet is working the stream is going
up but youtube is not putting the show
out guys we're just gonna have to talk
and chat then this was it was the
breaking point i was like van gaal
street rock they're like yeah they just
like we have no other networks available
uh
can you can can they are they doing
they're working on it right now
of course wait i've got it
yeah it's gonna it's gonna freeze on me
oh wait yeah yeah there's a delay yep
freezes on ian making the okay
it
signs
next moment i touched my finger to my
thumb
they're like look at this
you know honestly i thought this is i
think it's it was inevitable oh we're
back on oh the stream is back what's up
everybody did they switch the network no
that's that's live because that's me
holding the phone right believe we're
back give us a one in chat if you can
hear us wait this is this is weird
because i'm watching we are back i'm
actually watching my wait infinity
infinity infinity
conspiracy theorists
hey everybody sorry about that blip but
how many frames did it drop i'm not sure
if it looks like we were down for a few
minutes but your chat was still rolling
so
when i was talking about ducktales in
the old episode
a certain uh red and blue flag with an x
that was carried by a gray uniformed
army
don't say naughty words i know uh let me
just say for everybody who's listening
um
smash the like button yes subscribe to
timcast.com the full version and the
weird minute or so i think it's like two
minutes that dropped off will be in the
podcast version but uh our internet
didn't go out
our internet didn't go out we were i was
i i don't know if you guys saw me post
in the chat
everything was working but on youtube's
end something was not going through
now this has happened in the past where
we've been talking about something
and um related to china and we've had
weird youtube drop us off we are the age
of cyber wars upon us you never know
who's who's got effective you know
fingers in the pocket if you can hear me
smash the like button everyone it's the
only way we'll know exactly we need to
know i don't know is anybody out there
is the like button even like just
just to finish the story for
for my own autistic purposes um that
that episode of duck tales on disney
plus was removed
okay which one was it again reminding
you because about the confederacy red
army oh red flag
we were in tennessee and it was funny we
were at a gas station and there was like
the gas stations sell the confederate
flags and they called the rebel flag
right and there's like it's just like
funny seeing like a little girl holding
it up smiling like on the bag just
because of the way the left frames it
and the way they freak out but like when
you go to tennessee or the other states
it's like totally normal and not even
that big of a deal to anybody there yeah
we saw one flying on a hill on the way
back from tennessee i was like what is
happening that's wild i want to take a
moment to really appreciate the
technology that we have right now this
amazing streaming technology cameras
microphones the ability to communicate
across the world in blink of an eye with
someone from their home because like you
can see
just because we have it now doesn't mean
we're always going to or that we always
may take advantage of it while you have
it
yeah i mean yeah don't take it for
granted that's for sure yeah agree we
can unify a lot of people i was thinking
about hitler and how he was obsessed
with unification so we got to unify
correctly and i think the why the
founding fathers had it right because it
was a group of them doing it together it
wasn't one person i just noticed that we
got a ton of people smashing the like
button so i should i should i should do
better
i can't tell if you can hear me become a
member at timcast.com if you can hear me
it's the only way we'll know that's
right i'm like people actually did smash
the like button thank you so much
uh sorry what were you saying oh just
that we we're right on the verge of
doing something really great for society
if we work together i i think it's easy
to grow a cult group of people like as a
youtuber for yourself but you got to
remember the dictatorship type thing
doesn't work if we're going to use this
technology for good we got to do it
together speaking of uh cult youtubers
did we play the uh
which one mr no advertisers oh oh my god
this is nuts
yeah yeah
yeah
wow just just just just also full we'll
base our freedom around a constitution
not around people thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there